[Musik]
also es ist allein schon großartig dass
die behinderten sportler seit zwei
jahren beim bundesheer sein können und
dann vom bundesheer auch noch bester
behinderten sportler ausgezeichnet zu
werden ist natürlich große ehre war die
dame war die konkurrenz schon sehr hart
mit magdalena und diw und das hat er
natürlich dass man bundesrat einig beste
also dies mit den besten erfolgen ist
das schon sehr cool ja super
auszeichnung ist eine große ehre für
österreich bundesheer team des jahres zu
sein
mit freien ins kabel volle dass man das
geschafft habe es ist ziemlich cool dass
ein ausgezeichnet
naja man schon ein bisschen damit
gerechnet weil beide waren am 29
die größten opfer fielen sehr herzlich
darum ihn zu machen wir also die lose
bei passieren weil es gibt so viele gute
sportler weg sagt conradi er das recht
auf den preis und verlasse mich noch
einmal überraschen aber ich habe mich
sehr gefreut darüber und ja ich finde
toll
[Musik]